trekking through this we River Forest
Preserve and Ghana is tough going but
these conservationists are on a mission
researcher Gilbert Adam is here with
some American colleagues on a quest to
find a particular species of frog which
he first discovered a few years ago not
this one but the Giants squeaker frog
it's thought there are only about 30 of
them left I have to be careful here have
we seen this frog today no that's lovely
well the same genus piranha d'être a
trollop is a different one by a forest
one it's a good finds a great fine adam
has devoted his career to the giant
squeaker frog his work on its behalf has
sent him to distant countries that is
the sound of the giants cricket frog I
love frogs and this laughs of frogs
brought me to Germany brought me to
Berlin to be precise to the city's
natural history museum where Adam spent
18 months conducting research my nilla
has improved drastically there are about
80 frogs that okay in Ghana almost all
of them they have the specimens and I've
studied all of them and now with the
mouse that are developed I know where
each broke a case now Adam is back in
Ghana continuing his research in the
sweet liver forest reserve the frogs
natural habitat is also threatened by
logging Gilbert Adam shows his
colleagues from the US NGO save the
frogs the damage that's been wreaked by
the timber industry it's been a war for
us we cannot fight them what we have
been doing is to educate the local
people that this forest is not for any
timber company it's not for the
government it's for DD look out people
change is afoot in your Kron in just a
few years Gilbert Adam and his
organization have managed to enlist the
support of locals in protecting the
forest initially they didn't take his
work seriously and didn't see the point
of saving the frog and its habitat but
now they've helped plant 15,000
seedlings
today the village of your chrome is
welcoming the community chief the
celebration revolves around the frogs
and the frog conservationists Gilbert
Adam is even awarded a special honor I
mana cropping up with some pinned FS I
swear allegiance ought to Yunan annum to
help in the development of your Chrome
Oh they've made me the chief of the
environment environmental chief and it's
all because of nothing else but frogs
and the guys quick a frog in particular
the frog has become a symbol of the
community's commitment to protecting
their environment